[Music]
I got a little I got a little thick boy
update for you bud
our our buddy uh too lazy to try
all right so Joe Rogan actually gave his
opinion on all the Brennan Schaub and
Dana White drama and that went down he
finally commented on it on last week if
you don't remember what happened Brennan
shop thought there's some kind of
conspiracy theory behind UFC 279 he
thought that Hamza purposely missed way
or UFC told him to miss way or something
like that I'm not really sure but Dana
White responded to that and just called
Brennan an idiot and just went after him
and then now this is uh this is what uh
here real quick I play this
it came up on the last episode of Joe
Rogan's show
as soon as you don't give it to him
it's it Brandon Shaw he gave his opinion
on Dana that ate his ass alive like
piranhas it's so dumb I didn't talk to
him about that but first of all he's
wrong yeah he needed he's wrong about
the theory he look Brennan's my boy but
he needs a Handler
oh
oh
Joe here's the thing
Brennan does have a Handler
his Handler his big gay lion
and his Handler is not a good Handler no
he's more of an enabler he's more of a
valet
do you need someone like me around him
all the time what are you gonna do
I like I do like what Rogan says here he
look Brennan's my boy but he needs a
Handler he needs someone like me around
him all the time what are you gonna do
no no no here's why yeah and he'll go
yeah you're right as soon as you don't
even Rogan knows how [ __ ] stupid he
is right
like wow this is a dumb stupid idiot
give if all they're doing is fishing for
compliments to themselves so they can
let's see what Joe Rogan had us if you
give if all they doing is fishing for
compliments to themselves so they can
feel like something but as soon as you
don't give it to them
it's it Brandon Shaw he gave his opinion
on Dana that ate his ass alive like
piranhas it's so dumb I didn't talk to
him about that but first of all he's
wrong yeah he needed he's wrong about
the theory he look Brennan's my boy but
he needs a Handler he needs someone like
me around him all the time what are you
gonna do no no no here's why yeah and
he'll go yeah you're right I I get where
you you coming from with Brandon and
then it's like I don't to me I don't
understand why our community they hate
him
in a way like I don't know the
percentage but he gets a lot of [ __ ] if
you're spending any time anytime if
you're a busy man
I think he says they hate him I think
they're talking about Dana White is what
he's talking about a large percentage of
people in our business hey Dana White is
what he's referring to here you're a
family man you got you got kids you got
a wife you got [ __ ] to do and you're
spending any time arguing on Twitter
that is a waste of your life I get it
Rogan I mean I understand and that's not
necessarily wrong but unfortunately Joe
not a lot of people have a multi-million
multi-million listen to podcast where
you could go on and express your
opinions right like some people that
work every single day of their lives
only really have Twitter where they
could give their opinion and see what
other people you know what I mean like
you I get where Joe's coming from you
shouldn't be fighting with people on
Twitter I'm guilty of it I'll probably
do it again today but I'm just saying
like the other side of this is a lot of
people that don't have The Joe Rogan
Experience to vent on you know
I don't know just go on Rogan bro yeah I
don't know just start a multi-million
dollar podcasting gig I mean it's easy
and that's where and look Rogan
especially lately has been really on
point but that's that's the stuff where
I where I still think Rogan sometimes is
a bit out of touch is he has lost his
connection with the normal man
where you know we've talked about it
before when Rogan's like oh why don't
you just put a assault tank in your
spirit one of your five spare bathrooms
and you're like well most people don't
have a spare bathroom Joe most people
don't have us even if they do have a
spare one it's to use not to put a salt
tank in you know what I mean
it's like not a bigger place yeah not
every time somebody has an existential
crisis can they fly to Peru and do
Ayahuasca you know
like some people just kind of have to
deal with [ __ ] you know
like I don't know man it's like you know
[ __ ] can't get to work on time like
take a helicopter bro right right and
I'm saying look again especially Rogan's
pretty based on some [ __ ] but that's the
kind of stuff where he kind of kind of
gets a little disconnected that's a
waste of time but so funny Joe said he
needed a Handler but I think he's got
one isn't that Mark's job doesn't matter
he's kind of look after him well I am
really glad you brought that up